this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbuster
summer you love 2014's Godzilla for the
few minutes you could actually see
Godzilla
now get ready for a sequel that heard
your demands and massively over
compensates boom forcing the movie
Godzilla
Pam Moore Godzilla a POW who has atomic
breath two thumbs and is in a movie
title this guy
Godzilla king of the monsters strap it
for two long hours of non-stop kaiju
high jinks that you could almost see
when they're not obscured by blizzards
hiding behind waterfalls submerged
beneath the ocean flying through debris
and whatever is happening here because
Godzilla forbid we see a monster fight
in a clear sunny day never mind
when you're not squinting at particle
effects spend the rest of your time with
the humans of the movie look I'm really
sorry guys we kind of have to
featuring the Russell's your typical
nuclear family mom is a genocide on
maniac 11 is too good for Eggos now and
dad is a professional animal listen to
er follow their time-tested love story
as boy meets girl boy and girl make by
rhythmic acoustic device to talk to
whales Godzilla eats their son
I think girl reapplies will take to
control kaiju boy gets drunk and lives
with Wolves and Tony Stark's cabin girl
teams up with eco-terrorists to awaken
an ancient space monster boy up sneak
rival earth monster to enhance its power
and all right hold up all that stuff
happens in this movie how is it still so
boring
[Music]
sy has a cast with six Emmys and five
Oscar nominations between them tackles a
big-budget sharknado where Sally Hawkins
has killed off in the blink of an eye
Ken Watanabe tries to say Godzilla as
many times as he can before dying was
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous and Charles dance is also
present
we'll take you leaving brilliant actors
with nothing to do but track down giant
monsters fell to track and study
Godzilla on his own turf it allows us to
check him
we lost Godzilla dropped off the skin
near Venezuela let's keep looking
and when they find them stare like a
fish then washed up on dry land
[Music]
so strap in for the millionth modern
action movie where the villain wants to
destroy humanity in order to save the
earth we are that underwhelmed audiences
and disappointed at the box office but
since Godzilla vs. Kong is already in
production the franchise is literally
too big to fail but we're giving it no
matter what the real album is corporate
inertia rawr story clear eyes full
hearts
kaiju typical Chi Jewish mother Titan
team go an old man filled with regret
waiting to die alone why didn't she just
seduce these monsters hand of the King
Ghidorah respect the original and put
her in a tiny seashell I'd have given
Godzilla a third movie if I could thick
Lizzy hail Hydra come my lady come come
my lady you're my butterfly mother Oh
baby Mexico Wild Wings franchise
building need these things are there
seventeen and the bear from the shining
what the what is wrong with this family
let them fight club
I'll admit on my science knowledge comes
from watching Chernobyl but that's like
really really bad right we will continue
blockbuster summer next year attention
campers
lunch has been canceled today due to
lack of hustle deal with it
words are hard fortunately I don't speak
for a living
leave a message after the beep